aber jetzt nein aber bei den 100 ich bin
runtergefallen hey Leute und willkommen
bei einer neuen Folge t3c diesmal Folge
25 glaube ich
oderler ja ist auch glaube ich
mittlerweile jedenfalls so bei mir
ruckelt gerade ein ganz klein wenig aber
das sollte nicht weiter Stimmen
sein bzw sollt ihr euch daran W tödlich
schlimm ah jetzt Fall ich schon ganz
unten wieder oben g ze nein geh mal
einfach erstmal hoch ich versuch mal
dass dich die Frames gerade ein wenig
regulieren indem ich einfach sinnlos
rumstehe moment mal kurz anfangprung
hier so ich habe gerade mal Google
Chrome geschlossen hat aber nichts
gebracht egal ruckelt immer noch ein
wenig ich ich hab alles möglich gerade
offen ja du hast jetzt auch einen
hammergeilen PC müsstest du auch mal
kaufen neu vielleicht weiß nicht hast du
mal dran gedacht oder meinst du ja also
ich spare gerade eigentlich viel mehr
auf dem Laptop weil ich demnächst auch
erstmal zwei Wochen wieder in England
sein werde also da auch zur Schule gehen
werde zwei Wochen
und dann brauch wie kommst den dazu
Austausch irgendwie nee da gibt's eine
Dingen so eine bei uns in der Nähe so
eine so eine Fahrt da gehst du da auf so
eine englische Schule und ja keine
Ahnung fin ich ganz interessant mit ein
paar Freunden hinzufahren ist bestimmt
ganz cool so im Herbst ist das könnte
interessant sein würde mich sogar auch
reizen da bin ich raus aus dem
Alter brauchst halt nur
Freunde nein Spaß woll mal nicht so fies
sein hier so
fies
böse muss ich jetzt hier wieder alles
reißen das S gerade
so bin auch schon wieder runtergefallen
ich war schon relativ we hoch für mich
kurz verende ich find immer so geil wie
wir nebeneinander aneinander vorbei
reden im Let's
Play Fang Satz an nebenbei du so ah
fterfallen nicht so ah ich
auch ist aber irgendwie so Ken ich noch
jemanden Kumpel bei dem genau das gleich
ist wir können Stunden lang reden reden
ganzeinander vorbei aber jeder versteht
ein anderen aber quasi beide ganz
anderes
Thema so
komisch Bo ich muss mich gerade echt
konzentrieren damit ich jetzt nicht
wieder um die Ecke runterfalle und ich
runtergefallen die Ecke ist doch einfach
guck mal nein das danach das schaffe ich
irgendwie gar nicht mit meinen legs
gerade also es ruckelt jetzt nicht
extrem noch 30 fps aber halt nur 30 fps
ich kann F3 drücken ja das ist schon auf
dem roten
Bereich ja okay ich habe zwar auch nur
48 aber das liegt dann an einem Server
nicht an mir das liegt nicht an meinem
Server das liegt an nrado
ja nicht mich mit rein offline habe ich
400 ja offline hat jeder mehr ich habe
vorhin mit M anderen eine Map
aufgenommen das war einfach so eine
Insel nicht Skyblock sondern so eine
andere survival Map da hatte ich 500 FPS
das hat ich auch schon lang nicht mehr
bisher nur bei Skyblock ja klar weil
nicht so viele nicht so viel Landschaft
da ist ja es wir nicht so viel gerändert
genau ja kannst optify nur einstellen
dass nur sichtbare Geometrie gerändert
werden soll das bringt auch noch mal ein
kleines bisschen
was ich gerade gar nichts mehr ja ich
bin gerade wieder da auf diesen anderen
Leitern da oben nur mir hakt es gerade
ein wenig das ist echt
blöd boah PU wenn ich das jetzt schaffe
dann bin ich aber gut und ich bin
runtergefallen boah
m ich schau mal wieder dir eine Runde zu
vielleicht liegt do einfach daran dass
mein speicherg gerade Speicherplatz
gerade zu Ende geht warte ich kann mal
ganz kurz gucken ne zu weit drüber ne
400 GB frei ich wüsste nicht woran es
liegen sollte kann ich auch nicht sagen
ich habe auch noch ungefähr 1,2 TB
frei keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich ist die
Map einfach ziemlich groß und mein PC
kann das nicht bewältigen okay nicht ein
festplatt verteilt auf
zwei nein nein neinin Fall nicht er
fällt runter wir können über Supermärkte
reden wo gehst du am öftesten Einkaufen
ich weiß nicht wie ich daade drauf komme
aber nenn sich teegut teegut was ist das
denn kenn keiner von euch teegut also
ich nicht mein Gott wo wohnst du kennst
du Hit was hit Gesundheit
Hit nie gehört das ist offizieller
Sponsor von ersten fC Köln müsstest du
kennen also super Fußball dann
nicht na ja bei uns in der Nähe es gibt
ja so Aldi Kaufland Kaufland kennst aber
oder du kommst aus Hessen oder ich komme
nicht aus Hessen du kommst aus Hessen ja
das ja ich
dachte ich komme aus
nestfalen so nee das ist ein bisschen
weiter weg gibt's
nicht wfen ist hier der Ursprung des
ganzen Wissens von Deutschland also
teegut ist ein Supermarkt der
eher na ja gute Qualität al nicht so wie
Aldi sage ich jetzt mal sondern ein
bisschen hochwertigere ja ja das bla es
h eigentlich auch so bei uns gibt so
Aldi und Kaufland was eher so von der
jetzt nicht so toll ist auch nicht von
Einsortierung Personal und Aufbau und
dann gibt's halt Hit das ist
halt keine Ahnung irgendwie alles weiß
alles frisch geputzt so weißt du ja ja
klar so ein bisschen bisschen
hochwertiger halt od so gen na ja ja das
gibt's halt bei mir nicht das kenne ich
nicht kennst du teegut ich kan teegut ja
ich kann te gut aber es gibt viele
filial jedem Dorf jeder
Stadt ja wir haben auch noch so ganz
kleine supermärkt wir haben da ein der
heißt Erd market so ein türkischer Laden
verkauft fast nur Energy Drink kenne ich
nicht ja das ist do so ein so ein
kleiner Laden nein ich schaffe diesen
Sprung da nie auf dieser Ecke habe ich
noch kein einziges Mal
geschafft Sprung an der Ecke irgendwo
weiter oben meinst du dann
ja wir hängen h ziemlich hart an der
einen Stelle ist eine böse Challenge ja
ist wirklich eine böse Challenge böse
stage sage ich
mal Challenge an sich ging bisher
12 komm sind weiter ich glaube muss mich
mehr Konzentraten ich mach so Lari fari
Style und mich auch ein bisschen mehr
konzentrieren ich muss das ganze mal ein
bisschen langsamer
machen
ja und zack sofort geht der nächste
Sprung und der nächste geht auch und da
auch so B ja klappt ja alles wenn man
sich bisschen mehr konzentriert am Ende
ma jetzt beide auf einmal einem Run
komplett durch das wär's und du fällst
jetzt eh runter nein aber jetzt nein
aber bei den 100% oh ich bin runter
gefallen jetzt fällt du runter den
schaffe ich nie den Sprung den schaffst
du nie nee guck mal Arsch machst das
ganz einfach ohne
sprinten na ja dafür bin ich in anderen
Sachen besser wie
z.B
z.B se in der nächsten Folge nein wir
haben noch 8
Minuten sieht Moment relativ gut aus
aber auch nur relativ konzentriere D ich
mach langsam ja das ist böse hier die
Stelle nein da geht's nicht ich springe
oben dagegen bin auch gerade wieder
runtergefallen ach Mensch ich kann ja
heute gar nichts reißen ja doch die
ersten vier challenges kann ich
reißen ja ich bin ja auch noch dann mit
durchgekommen
teilweise du bist mehr so für die
schwierigen Sachen verantwortlich oh
mann schon wieder
runtergefallen Bo so das kriegen wir hin
kriegen wir auch noch hin guckst du hier
guckst du da guckst du hier noch mal
guckst du
hier habe ich geguckt e das ist echt
böse komm weiter ich wollte dich nicht
schlagen ich wollte nur ein Block
abbauen ich kann D nicht mehr schlagen
ich bin zu weit weg
verdammt mus komm um die Ecke rum um die
Ecke
rum schlag mich nicht ich lauf jetzt vor
dir okay ich bin
runtergefallen
ach her jemine das ist echt furchtbar
können wir jetzt hier noch halbe Stunde
dran sitzen ich freue mich wenn ich
nicht mehr
aufnehme gehen endlich wieder die Frames
ein bisschen hoch Fall nicht hä wo stehe
ich gerade bei dir in der Luft stehst du
zwischen den beiden Treppen cool oh
jetzt bist du runter h ruhig
weiterlaufen können h was steht da
eigentlich no smoking
auf ich bin eh nicht raucher von mir aus
das heißt ich denke wir sind hier in
einem Restaurant und nicht in einem
Supermarkt war ja eigentlich habe ich e
auch gedacht ich weiß nicht du bist h
Supermärkten angefangen zu reden von
daher na ja obwohl im Supermarkt darf
man wahrscheinlich auch nicht rauchen ja
aber ich glaube da merkt nicht so
schnell einer wie im Restaurant weil es
einfach viel größer und verwinkelter ist
so der Sprung den schaffe ich eh nicht
ich habe geschafft mein Gott oh mein
Gott
geschafft ich war so
weit ich waron kurz Schluss oben ich
auch
ja jetzt verkack ich wieder hier beim
beim ersten wenn man das ganze ab kürzen
gibt eh nur wieder Ärger von den
Zuschauern ja bedenk du hast gut über
5000 blicke jetzt gerade im Nacken die
dir zuschauen jeden Fehler den du
tust ja l first ja hier komm ich huch
auch gleich
mal ich nicht raus ja kannst do Türen
offen
machen stehst vor so ein vorem zaunor
mein kommst da nicht raus einfach
rechtsklick Spark einfach
rechtsklick jetzt komme ich nicht die
rum das gibt's nicht woll wir sagen wenn
ich wenn ich wenn wir es am Ende von
diesem Part nicht schaffen cheaten wir
uns ganz kurz hoch und dann starten wir
die Aufnahme neu oh entschuldigung ich
wollte gerade hin schlagen damit die
Zuschauer das sehen ja nee ja ja ja das
Problem ist kriegen wir nicht so
wirklich hin gell ist halt so so so eine
Lappen stage die wir Lappen nicht
hinkriegen weil wir Lappen sind eben mit
uns kannst du ein Boden aufwischen
deshalb heißen wir ja
so losp komm Boden aufwiischen
ja ach mensch was sollen wir denn machen
hier keine Ahnung geht nicht Hallo ist
eine mitternachtsaufnahme da dürfen wir
failen okay und wir dürfen auch nicht so
viel quatschen weil ich habe gerade
schon aufgenommen sehr lange Spark hat
auch schon heftigen Tag hinter sich was
wer das gesagt ich okay au ich habe
nicht viel aufgenommen nur vier Let's
Play folgen ein Tutorial ansonsten ich
habe 14 Folgen
aufgenommen ja egal egal egal solange
die Stimme noch hält hallo s es noch
einigermaßen Spaß macht du hast gemint
das Bock auf auf komm wir hauen jetzt
noch bis 3 Uhr durch bis
3 Berufsrisiko meine Stimme tut
weh ja da muss mal gucken wie das mit
den ganzen Sängern ist in Popstars von
heute jtin hat sich so die Stimme
ruiniert hat eine
tolle ja das das ist so so eine
Geschichte Justin bber allgemein da das
ist doch jetzt auch ein Thema wo man
diskutieren kann oh ich hab kein auf
oh aber das was er geleistet hat muss
ich schon echt sagen ist schon heftig
ich fin seine Musik selber nicht toll
aber ich habe es vor kurzem noch nie
Lied von dem gehört B ich einfach mal so
überlegt als ob nee auch nicht im Radio
so bis V kurz bis ich einfach just for
fun mal gesagt hab so jetzt jetzt der
wird überall runtergt über der we
kapierst all nicht warum jetzt hörst s
mein Lied von dem an und dann habe ich
mal geguckt was war dieses Baby oder wie
das heißt von gen 700 Millionen Aufrufe
das ist das meist geklickte ja meist
geklickte Video
weltweit du willst du kannst ja
hochrechn wie viel der da schon
eingenommen hat jetzt ne Geld
praktisch okay Musik ist halt jetzt na
ja okay ansichtsache aber an sich vom
vom Typ ja also sag mal so es gibt da
viele Leute die sagen oh mein Gott Let's
Play das gibt doch gar nicht wie tief
kann man nur
sinken nach dem Motto aber bei jtin
Bieber sagen echt viel mehr weil du
einfach ein viel größeren Vergleich hast
mit anderen Musikern und wenn man andere
popmiker vergleicht das da hat er schon
eine übelste Piepsstimme und macht echt
total schwule Songs wie man echt sagen
will z.B Baby Ich will dich nicht
vermissen so schnullsten Songs weiß du
also ich kenne jetzt keine in meinem
Freundeskreis der meint Justin Bieber
ist toll aus vielleicht ein paar Mädels
aber was bei mir der Fall ist ich
bewundere ihn eigentlich dafür was er
quasi hingekriegt hat und zwar mit einem
Youtube Video sowas von viele Klicks und
sich dadurch quasi durch eigene eigene
wie sagt man eigenes durch sich selber
hat er sich quasi so hoch gepusht im
Prinzip schon ja ne hat entlich Erfolg
dabei gehabt also hat schon was aus sich
gemacht also hat seinem Leben was
erreicht auf jeden Fall der wird mehr
verdienen als 100 Leute von euch
zusammengerechnet ja sagen wir jetzt mal
der jahreseinommen bestimmt von was ich
ein paar Millionen me oder ja ich glaube
mal ich habe irgendwan gehört von meist
verdienten Stars oder so die die liegen
so bei 50
Millionen nee los komm los los mach ihn
rein mach ihn rein nein genau die Stelle
da fehle ich auch immer genau die
stellech Gott die exakt die gleiche
Stelle ich glaube es gibt doch einfach
viele Leute die neidisch sind und viele
die einfach mit dem Strom mitziehen die
einfach auch sagen ja wenn der die sagen
alle mit Justin Bieber ist doof ich sag
auch mal der ist doof also ich selber
mag seine Musik auch nicht aber ich
finde man sollte zumindest das
respektieren was er geleistet hat na
okay jetzt ist die Frage beurteilst du
einen Menschen nach demem seiner Musik
die er macht weil kennst du ja das
wollte ich auch noch sagen ich mein ähm
dass viele Menschen einfach nur neidisch
sind und einfach nur mitziehen habe ich
ja schon gesagt aber
ja wie du halt gerade auch meintest ist
auch gut äh dass viele ihn einfach
beurteilen nur wegen seiner Musik also
natürlich ein bisschen kann man das da
drauf beziehen und so weil Musik ja auch
teilweise echt ein paar wahre Sachen
drin sind über die man spricht und so
weiter aber ich finde auch dass man
ja die Musik kann noch so gay sein wie
dann sagt man die Musik ist voll gay
aber man man sollte auf jeden Fall nicht
sagen Justin Bieber ist gay weil der hat
glaube ich sogar eine Freundin ja
sowieso ach so 15 Minuten ja sowieso und
wenn dann was für eine noch in
anführungszeich Selena Gomes sowieso 15
Minuten ja ich weiß ich sehe es tschüss
nächste Folge bei Spark jo
schchüs